hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
nano emulsion formulation
and characterization for life science
and industrial markets
presented by dr john costello the
technical sales specialist
at beckmann culture life sciences i am
tracy esta martin of labyrinths
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by
beckmann culture life sciences for more
information on our sponsor
please visit beckman.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the
ask box located on the far left of your
screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd now like to introduce our presenter
dr john costello for a complete
biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr john costello you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much tracy i appreciate
it
um as she mentioned i'm going to uh
have a talk today regarding our
nano-emulsion formulation
characterization activities
uh first i'd like to just thank my my
colleagues
derek and edgar for their support in
putting this together
uh in particular i'd like to emphasize
edgar's contribution
he's a our application lab specialist
in our applications lab down in miami
florida
and he's done a lot of the technical
uh testing of our data that we'll be
presenting
so just a quick outline of our talk
today
um a brief review of some of the market
applications of emulsion
uh get into some of the different uh
types of emotions
and terms uh from there segue to
one of some of the key quality control
aspects of
emulsions particularly the particle size
analysis
i'll then go into a couple of case
studies
focused on the nano emulsions again
particularly
flavored oil emulsions or soda
concentrates
as well as some cbd oil nano emulsions
uh we'll finish up with a brief summary
and then get into
some questions and answers
so emulsions uh have a variety of
different
uh characteristics that basically the
one of the key things is the there's two
or
several mixtures that are not uh
miscible they're not
soluble in one another they don't uh
they don't like to mix well
such as oil and water and so one of the
things that you have is a majority of
the emulsion
called the continuous phase the minority
of emotion is the dispersed phase so
oil and water is a good working example
that
is typically used either oil and water
or water
in oil depending on the the percentages
differences but you'll have droplet
formation
uh on those and it's a matter of uh
how long does that stay uh
how how long can these droplets be uh
in that present state one of the ways to
go and help that
is through some emulsification
enhancers are called emulsifiers but in
general
uh there's a variety of different uh
markets that
utilize this capability both in
pharmaceuticals drug delivery
of course food and beverage but
industrial applications of
metal working and oil refining building
materials paints inks etc
just a couple of examples to sort of
start working through
uh milk of magnesia is is a
long-standing
uh emulsion uh put together
for magnesium hydroxide
uh in water solution from all the way
back from the 1700s
uh as well boston loan has a
uh this eye drop lubricant
emollient it is a
water in oil droplet
it actually allows you to
dropper the oil with a little bit of
water in there
to help prevent dry eyes
as well you can get into the lotions etc
for for dry skin etc
industrial-wise asphalt
is an emulsion technology a fairly large
size but um the particle size is
is critical there because it's going to
affect
um various properties such as drying
time
the consistency of the product as well
as strengths
what's shown on the right hand side uh
below
is several different formulations
that have uh what the cohesion strength
is
of the asphalt as a function of particle
size
um basic take away on that the smaller
the particle size
the higher the cohesive strength of the
asphalt so there's a key attribute
related to size and which become part of
the scene here
uh but that's how it affects some of the
properties
um an axonal nobel uh a variety of other
industrial
accounts have a lot of literature
associated with this stuff which can be
obtained
from their websites
uh pigments and dyes tanks a variety
uh they're all emulsion um fairly large
size
because in this particular case you
still will wind up having to stir
things up but for the most part we want
to try to
keep them relatively stable in there
without too much mixing but certainly
when being applied
onto a paper or painting of a house
you want to have that fairly consistent
delivery and so we get that by creating
these emulsions
with some emulsification to get to a
certain particle size which will
uh perhaps have some additives as well
that uh
help with the uh various optical
properties of these
as well you can get into the stability
after washing
uh based on certain additives that go
into it so
uh it's an assemblage of all these
particles that come together
which collectively can be balled up and
uh stabilized
into an emulse motion uh that will
impart
useful properties
a very unique one is the lubricant
that can be on the edge of that
razor that many of us will use day to
day
uh it's a a nano emulsion that will
based on the shear action from moving it
across your leg will
deposit some of the oil which will help
with lubricating the surface
and giving you a nice nice
shave
as well there's a number of specialty
channels chemical manufacturers uh that
have
uh lots of emulsion formulations
uh as well as emulsifiers uh that they
offer
uh in part i i showed this particular
slide from dao
uh just to sort of highlight some of the
markets that
uh on the left-hand side there uh
many many uses for various emotions that
they offer to the uh the customer the
market
uh capabilities
so let's get into a little bit of uh
emulsion basics
um basically uh we come down to
the ability to control the hydrophobic
hydrophilic
nature of these uh mixtures of liquids
in in the case of oil and water again
where oil is hydrophobic it doesn't like
to mix with the water
in part because of the nonpolar nature
of the molecular structure
there's large carbon chains that
exist uh and they like to hang out with
one another they don't like
to mix with the water conversely
the water uh and vinegar
uh vinegar is a hydrophilic it loves to
mix with water
um and because of the polar nature of
of the carbonyl groups uh hydroxide ions
and so that's what colors the water
droplets the
oil or the the
vinegar inside of the oil droplets now
the
oil water mixture can be mixed up
further but without much help they will
start
to segregate out and so it's very hard
to keep that
emulsified unless
one starts to use the emulsifiers
emulsification can be enhanced
by using these amphiphilic
components which are basically
they have both hydrophilic and
hydrophobic parts
and help to mediate the charges
between the polar and nonpolar
molecules helping to emulsify
given that the emulsification and
imparts
a lot of useful physical property
there's lots of emulsifiers out there
for different uh
material systems and as well
they can be very proprietary uh the
demand can be very high and
obviously some of these can cost quite a
bit of money
as mentioned before uh emotion size is
is a very critical
factor in imparting some of the emulsion
properties
what's shown here is some sizing
information
for three different uh processes
that were run from a customer site
and looking at having certain pass fail
criteria
they process b obviously hit
all the right um sizing requirements
which would uh allow it to be moved
forward
uh process a obviously was over milled
and was going to have a lot
smaller particles overall particle size
which would cause a fail for whatever
reason
for that particular material system
likewise
process c was not milled enough and so
addressing the particle size
distributions uh
is what one of the critical factors are
for
monitoring these emotional emotions
very useful paper uh by
some of the folks in um in mit
but uh gucca at all um i've
taken a table from them
because it gives some useful talking
terms as far as
uh various emotions nomenclature
uh on the left hand side we have uh
macro emulsions
which are similar to what were shown in
some of those lotions
and obviously mayonnaise and other
uh these larger format emulsions
anywhere from one to 100 microns or you
can even go much larger than that
basically they're they're going to be
spherical in nature
um but they're not very stable
they like to start separating out as we
mentioned earlier
um various methods of preparation you
can emulsify
by trying applying high and low energy
to them
but again they're not going to be very
stable they'll probably start to
kinetically start to
cause creaming etc
and their polydispersity that's the
breadth of the
size distribution that you may find in
those uh you can see
up there with the picture there that
there's a variety of different particle
sizes
conversely on the right hand side the
micro emulsions
these are thermodynamically stable
implementations of emulsions you can see
a phase diagram
shown uh on there where there are cert
there are certain areas of formulation
and temperature
etc where you have uh thermodynamic
equilibrium
uh and then there are also regions of
um non-equilibrium which would cause the
breakdown of
uh the emulsions um these
are very they form on their own they can
get uh
anywhere from 10 to 100 nanometers
uh and fairly easy to form when mixed in
the right proportions and at the right
temperatures etc
the thermodynamic stability is what
helps with that
however if you move out of that
stability zone
you will now start to have the breakdown
of the uh the emotions
uh a mixture of the in between these two
is with the nano emulsions um
anywhere from 20 to 500 nanometer
approximately um again they're going to
be spherical
uh we use a lot of high and low energy
methods
to particularly high energy to really
get to smaller and smaller uh values
of size this imparts
while thermodynamically unstable
they impart a kinetic stability meaning
that
depending on the size these will remain
stable for
periods of time that are going to be
engineered
to accomplish what their mission is
in in their application
so there's a variety of particle sizing
techniques out there in the industry
i've shown a chart here that has a
variety of techniques
uh on the lower end going from a size
of angstrom level all the way up through
to the millimeter level
the yellow band displayed
is what is used with the nano emulsion
size range anywhere from the 10
nanometer
up to about 500 nanometer or so
i highlight two particular sizing
techniques
that are very useful in emulsion
technology
uh laser diffraction as well as dynamic
light scattering
in part because of the ability to size
in that
range uh do it with fairly high accuracy
and precision
and have a fairly good ease of use
there are other techniques such as sem
and tem um various other
of these that are in that size range
that can be orthogonal
testing but also have some pros and cons
that would show the
utility of it or cause a lot more
you know the ease of use may not be as
uh as nice
so let's talk a little bit about dynamic
light scattering
uh particles suspended in a solution
will move
randomly under brownian motion dependent
on
the particle size the temperature and
the viscosity of the solution
in which they are
the light fluctuation um as
as particles move around and are hit by
the laser beam will deflect
light onto the photo detector comparing
to a reference beam
one can get the light intensity
fluctuations
as a function of time in microseconds
this can be used to
evaluate the decay rate
of of the signal
during the fluctuation of of the light
as it's
being monitored the autocorrelation
analysis allows you to go and fit
the that decay term to a particular size
of diffusional model based on the stein
stokes einstein
relationship from this uh the
hydrodynamic radius solution can be
calculated
displayed over on the right hand side
the autocorrelation function is
probably the most critical
measurement that you want to make for
dynamic light scattering to get useful
and meaningful interpreted
interpretations of the size
i emphasize this a lot with a lot of the
customers that we deal with for setting
proper expectations about dls
if you look at the signal up on the top
left you've got the
solvent signal uh which is basically
highly filtered the lack of any
particles there
and you're you're basically going to be
seeing this the the noise floor
of the detector system with the laser on
fairly quick drop off um and
and then it just goes to uh baseline of
1.0
so the right hand side on top is a small
particle
a unimodal distribution and what you
have there
is the autocorrelation function is a
nice decay term
that goes down to the 1.0 baseline
at you know approximately 100
microseconds
conversely a large particle on the lower
left
has a similar kind of decatur
curve but at a much higher
time constant uh the microseconds is
more on the order of about a
uh a millimeter uh a millisecond
and that's what dictates the size the
the the smaller particles travel much
faster
in this solution than the larger
particles
and therefore have a a faster
time autocorrelation curve faster time
constant
now if you mix these two you can
actually see how
it broadens out the overlay of
both curves and so you can fit unimodal
distributions to the multimodal
population there
and get a multimodal population
on the next slide
i get into looking at that this is a
very useful
process to go through for understanding
what kind of information you can
receive from dlf
we use polystyrene latex particle
standards reference material
on the top left i have four different
um curves uh measurements of
100 200 300 and 500 nanometer beads
and you can see the delay curves move
very consistently in
into higher uh microsecond delay
uh based on their size
uh down below on the on below that on
the lower left
are the three or four uh distribution
curves overlaid on one another
and again these are the unimodal
populations and so they
have a very sharp peak
um modal modal value
and they have a fairly tight um
distribution of particles the
polydiversity index is a factor that is
used
the breadth of the distribution
now if you mix several of these
particles together
um then you have a little bit more
difficulty
uh measuring you can what's shown on the
right hand side
is the overlay of the four unimodal
populations but the green curve
is triplicate runs of a trimodal
solution
of 100 300 and 500 nanometer
beads the solution for that
gives you that broad broader
distribution
which is the sum of all three of those
particle populations the general rule of
thumb
is that you can do baseline resolution
only with diameters that are
greater than approximately 3x
the dls will have a hard time resolving
tighter populations and so what happens
is you wind up
having to go with
using either that broad distribution
result or
try to go with some other technique
or resolving these uh populations if
they're tighter
a useful one of the one of the key
uh value adds of dynamic light
scattering
is the ability to measure the zeta
potential or the electrophoretic
mobility
with nanoparticle populations or
submicron and nanoparticles
electrostatics become that much more
important the ability to
diffuse or to eliminate vendor wall
forces that will aggregate the small
particle population
is critical for molecules or
these small particles can be stabilized
both with
steric as well as electrostatic methods
steric methods are you coat the
particles with a polymer a non a polar
a nonpolar substance which basically
shields the particles from interacting
with one another
electrostatic methods are similar to
like the emulsification where
you can create a charge around the
surface
of that which will create a a repulsive
force and keep the primary particles
from
attracting to one another this is what's
called the zeta potential
zeta potential refers to the
it roughly equates to the charges
that are associated with the particle uh
both around the particle but in the
solution itself
so the data potential is always going to
be environmentally constrained to
the solution that the particles are in
so the technique basically uses an
electric field
which oscillates back and forth and
you're going to monitor
now the mobility of the particles
under the influence of the electric
field and they're directly related to
the charge of the particles the higher
the charge
the more movement back and forth you'll
be seeing
um through the various analyses one can
determine the zeta potential and
a typical rule of thumb for good
colloidal stability
due to the zeta potential is typically
plus or minus
30 millivolts if you have
that kind of voltage associated with
individual particles you can be assured
or higher
you can be assured that you will have
good
primary particle populations and not
have to worry about aggregates etc
one of the aspects of the zeta potential
which can be uses
in in some of these applications is
things like
deflocculation or flocculation both
for clays as well ceramics as well as
uh you know some uh
correcting for effluent waters but uh
there you're manipulating the zeta
potential going through
the isoelectric point which is going to
be where you're reducing
the the the the uh
your your zeta potential and and causing
attraction which will lead to
aggregation and subsequent precipitation
of large particles
so you can work both sides of the zeta
potential equation that way
so let's get into laser diffraction uh
particle size analysis as well
this is a higher resolution sizing
technique
uh but has also a very wide dynamic
range
um it is based on using a light source
which is uh shined through
a flow cell that has particles purposely
dropped in front of it whether it be
in liquid or in a dry powder
and the light it gets diffracted it gets
bent in angular fashion which can be
picked up by the
by the photo detectors and so there's an
angular
specificity associated with the
light that can be directly related to
particle size
on the right hand side you can see a
series of curves which relate to the
diffraction
patterns for spherical particles of
varying sizes from
20 microns all the way down to 10
or 100 nanometers and you can see the
first
minimum there's min and max
interference that causes the diffraction
rings for spherical particles
and so by looking at that first minimum
at the angle at which
it was uh a minimum will give you
uh what the size is and so
what one can do with this is to look at
the flux intensity patterns that are
generated
with a over a broad range of
material or broad range of particle
sizes
and go and extract out what the size
distribution is
both number as well as volume
percentages
and you can do this very accurately
in order to move down to the
extremely low particle sizes
we have used uh pids detection system
which i'll discuss in in a moment on the
next slide
but this allows you to go from the 400
to from the 400 nanometer range
all the way down to 10 nanometers and
this is used primarily for the nano
emulsions that's why i'm
bringing it up so we have
our ls 13 320 just a brief
limited commercial break breaks our
ls 13320xr is our latest
version of our laser fraction offering
the xr stands for the extended range
again we have this wide dynamic size
range that we can measure particles
across a range of 10 nanometers
all the way to 3 500 microns 3.5
millimeter
we have both wet and dry modules that
can be used
um we can go and without any kind of
model we can have the algorithm go and
solve
for the distribution based on the light
parameters that it has measured uh with
the main beam
uh we have a 780 nanometer laser with
126 space detectors to give you that
angular
specificity um and that gives us this
high resolution of
and allows us to really discern these
very small populations that exist
particularly in that in that particular
size range the 400 nanometer to
3500 micron again pid
is polarization intensity differential
scattering
basically it's looking at the horizontal
and vertical components of
three different wavelengths of light at
six different
uh side scatter angles this gives us a
lot of information about small particles
anywhere from 2 microns down to that 10
nanometer
very discerning and is used primarily
in that exclusively for doing the now
emulsion sizing it uses meat theory
scattering
so we need to know what the refractive
index model is
but it can give you very accurate
analyses
fully automated operations anywhere from
15
to 60 second run times uh and
for pharmaceutical applications we have
full compliance with gmt
uh and the ability to do iqoq
so let's go and look at the reference
particle testing here much the same way
with the
dynamic light scattering we use
reference particles polystyrene latex
feeds and
others um on the top left we have 100
nanometer
um standard uh which can you can see how
very sharp that
distribution is uh the one below that
is the tri-modal that we were referring
to before
this particular one is uh 80 nanometers
200
and 500 nanometer uh polystyrene beads
mixed uh you can see how we can baseline
resolve
uh those peak populations that's totally
uh
significantly better than the what the
dlf could do
as before i actually show an overlay of
the dls result that we measured with
this particular
trimodal solution versus the
laser diffraction shown on the right
hand side
up above is a
a trimodal solution that is up in the
hundredths of micron range
which again shows you the kind of
resolution capabilities that you can get
with the main beam interestingly we can
have
both trimodal solutions in the same
uh popul same uh carrier solution
and if you were to measure that
basically what you would see
initially is the that
the large trimodal result
however we have the ability to turn off
the main beam because of the
high end higher intensity scattering the
you can't really see that well the it
doesn't it does the
the small molecule population does not
become significant
however we can turn off the main beam
and just look at the pid
and lo and behold you would have that
trimodal result
so it's an interesting utility of that
for looking at
large versus small populations okay
let's
get into some of our case studies uh
flavored oil emulsions
um the coca-cola
pepsi you know concentrate
the secret ingredient that gets mixed
with the beverages that's what it's all
about
we have displayed a big application is
soft drinks
as well there's a whole variety for food
and beverage
flavorings that are shown up on the
left-hand side
all of them involve use of emulsions
emulsifiers
to keep stable for their intended use
when they are then
um sent to customers that then have them
mix in various uh formats and time
frames
i'll go to the next slide to
get into that uh flavored all emulsions
have a variety of flavonoids
emulsifiers other ingredients to impart
certain characteristics
they like to they need to have sizing
uh to impart a stability over and shelf
life
of the product if not sized correctly
over time
it will break down as we were mentioning
before
and so particularly in case of the of
the
soda market
concentrate plants need to go and
have some stability when they create
that
emulsion because they're now shipping it
to a third-party bottling plant
and then and so they need to have that
stability
otherwise you get into a range of
problems where they don't accept the
product when it's there
and these are extremely high large
volume formats hundreds of gallons at a
time and so
what they're really looking for is to
impart that kinetic stability
for a several week time period at least
uh
for each of those different photo
emotions
just from a slow flow chart point of
view
you know those circular areas are
the initial formulation uh
at the syrup producer um the final qc
check when it's shipped um they
release that lot and then it's sent to
the distributor
whether it be by boat or truck etc
uh the bottling plants and so they
typically will want to
confirm that the sizing is correct
before they commit it to
the full bottling process at that point
it's it's basically done it's up to the
customer to drink it
before they have it sitting on the shelf
too long
so there's several different ways to
test the emulsion stability of these
concentrates uh the old school has been
the ring test
you put some of the material
once it's been emulsified homogenized
into
a clear vial put it up on the shelf
and and watch for it to create if it
forms a ring
that's where the emulsion is is creaming
and creating a ring around the top
surface that
that process though when done
appropriately for
kinetic stability could take days weeks
or even longer
and so they've moved over the years to
looking at some optical imaging to do
that sizing and
um they have limited
been limited to approximately one micron
at the time
and so some of these concentrate
manufacturing
facilities came to us to say hey what
about your
laser refraction system would you be
able to
uh provide us lower
values because in the in particular case
with the optical
uh imaging uh basically they were only
able to see
about half the population and so that
was very challenging to
say okay the peak is exactly at where
that measurement was
laser fraction was went in we've we've
done this with a number of
of customers uh and and distributed the
the units worldwide
um because of the ability to go anywhere
from 10 nanometers up to 2000 microns
with water-based as uh kind of emulsions
um the method is very uh reliable
uh easy to use has the red the
accuracy and performance capability and
can actually be
282c from one plan to the next
so here's that just uh two of different
examples of some flavored oil emulsion
um these are triplicate runs of both of
those
um you can see where one particular one
has
a mean size of about uh 200 nanometers
uh whereas the other one uh is a little
bit larger in size
about at about 300 nanometer
but these would be uh once again they
would have passed bail criteria that are
related to
um the the modal values or perhaps the
d10 d50 d90s which are the
um the breadth of the of the emotion
sizes
but it's all dependent on what the
customer feels is the
the appropriate uh sizing for that
with the legalization of cannabis
products uh over the last couple of
years
we've been approached by a number of
customers that were interested
in analyzing their uh various emulsions
um so one of the things we did was we
went and picked up some
cbd oils at a local uh
store and wanted to just do
some testing of that as is as well as
looking at some um higher energy
emulsification using uh the sonicator
assembly that i have shown pictorial on
the right hand side
um this was capable of generating 200
watts of power uh
it's fairly large probe what you can see
is a
a beaker that is it's inserted into
that was used as a coolant reservoir
uh the scintillation vials are actually
shown in the front
of that uh that the picture of the
assembly
in various states you can see as
is we received the material it was
fairly turbid
fairly large particle size i'll get into
that in a minute
but with the emulsification um
due to the high power sonication
treatment
um and the use of some of the
emulsifiers
or surfactants we were able to uh bring
the particle size significantly down to
the point where
it was translucent uh you can literally
not see the optical scattering
of the submicron components
and so we went and evaluated both laser
refraction as well as dynamic light
scattering with these samples
um cbdo oil number one i
again have three different sample
results um
and i'm going to go through each of them
um basically
pointing out the same uh the results
that we have uh in this particular case
the cbd oil
i show the on the top left hand side
is the as is size distribution
uh it was a a micron
sized kind of emulsion just a mixture it
wasn't expected to be
a nano emulsion per se and
the three different ones that i selected
had various flavonoids and other
mixtures
uh i didn't have any clue as to what the
size was going to be
i just wanted to start with some of
these
and and begin with what the as
is state was and then from there go and
emulsify and see what the results are
below that curve the top curve on the
lower left
is the final uh value as measured
with the laser diffraction system um i
believe
that it was on the order of uh 60
nanometer
size modal value on the top
right you can see the autocorrelation
function
curve uh for that that same
sample we literally just extracted some
of the
uh emulsion uh solution from
the laser diffraction system and put it
into our dls system
and you can see the sizing result
and we below that what we've done is
actually overlaid
the dls curve with the
ls result interestingly
you can see there's fairly good
correlation with the modal values
but you can see it's significantly
sharper
sizing results with the laser
diffraction which
is implied by the higher resolution
capabilities
that a laser refraction had
okay so cbd oil number two
very similar we did not uh i did not put
the sizing result
of the as-is material but again uh
each in each case they were
approximately in that tens of micron
kind of range
um but we were able to bring them down
uh to
the nano emulsion size uh with the
application of powder uh power of from
the sonicator
in this particular case we see about 130
uh nanometer size a little bit broader
solution
um on the tail end
but again fairly good autocorrelation
function the sizing result with dls
and once again uh fairly good agreement
between
the uh the dlf and the ls results
uh the the slight disagreement in the
modal value is probably the result of
that little tail
on the low end from the dls
uh parameters that it was seeing
and lastly
the we have cbd oil number three
similar results everything there you can
see a little bit more of a tail here as
well
um with some of the ingredients that
were in there
making it different we basically applied
the same
uh sonication to each of the three so
these are a direct comparison of how
each of them assembled into that
particular sizing
value in this particular case 110
nanometer value for the
dls result and approximately
slightly lower than that for the
modal value with the dls or excuse me
with the ls
value so
in summary just want to go and say that
there are a myriad of applications
across life science and industrial
markets
emulsion stability is a key quality
attribute
that will impart a kinetic stability
uh which is very useful when for a
variety of these different applications
both
you know transporting to you know
manufacturing sites
the ability to have it coat very well
on the the house that you're painting
and drug delivery the ability to
go through the body uh and without being
breaking down and or being captured by
the liver or the kidney um
we used two different showed two
different uh detection techniques for
this
uh both a little bit higher resolution
laser diffraction
as well as the dynamic light scattering
um
and the merits of these techniques were
discussed in two case studies
at this point i will thank you all for
your time and attention and open it up
for
questions and comments uh i'll pass it
on to tracy
uh thank you dr costello for your
informative presentation
we're going to now start the q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so we have a lot of questions coming in
very interesting and we're going to get
started with our first question
so dr costello our first question is
uh vaccines are a hot topic at the
moment
are these analysis techniques applicable
to vaccine emotions
yes yes they are and they have been um
vaccine emulsions have been around for a
long time
um they've sort of progressed with
the the technology that's available uh
to to the formulators
um a lot of the micron sized emulsion
technology
has been the real workhorse
but we are and they they
certainly use uh emulsifiers to
stabilize
uh the mixtures um i have seen
numerous uh documents or publications
that are starting to go down into the
uh the nanometer size um properties
of some of these vaccines for for
delivery of the drugs
so yes they are clickable okay
our next question is in your case
studies
i assume you were using me theory sizing
algorithms for your size analysis
how did you obtain the refractive index
models required for
me theory calculations
okay yes again um
theory um maybe perhaps uh just a quick
um reference to that uh meat theory
is a stronger algorithm
solution um over what we call
fraunhofer uh theory
fraunhofer was developed in the 1800s
for laser
light diffraction uh it is
a rigorous mathematical solution
but it deals with particles that are
significantly larger than the wavelength
of light
so in general terms you know you could
use
fraunhofer uh above um
about 50 micron particle sizes
and get uh use very good results um
the this does not require the use of
refractive index indices
now meat theory is as we were
particle size analysis was becoming
further hume
uh to lower and lower particle sizes
me another mathematician from germany
developed an algorithm that really a
theory that
basically addresses the
optical properties that are affecting
the light distribution
of the particles particularly in the
size ranges where they're getting close
to
the wavelength of light
the what's required there is that they
have to have
a refractive index model of the particle
as well as the solution in which they're
being dispersed to do the correct
solutions so with meat theory
it's typical practice to use a
refractometer to
measure what the uh the
real part of the refractive index is
of both the liquid as well as the uh
the solid particles but as well
you can get into the imaginary part
which is the
absorption of particles uh depending on
the amount of
absorption of light that occurs you can
correct for that
using the imaginary part that can be
done with a
a uv vis spectrophotometer looking at
the absorbance of light as a function of
wavelength
the ls-13320 has a
complex refractive index modeling
capability that allows you to plug in
both the real and imaginary part as a
function of wavelength dependence
because again with our pid
detection system we have the three
different wavelengths
so to answer the question uh we
would use those um refractive index
measurement techniques um refractometers
and
uv vis absorbance
what range of reproducibility values did
you obtain
with the flavor oil emulsion testing
those triplicate runs were pretty tight
yeah um so the
one of the nice things about the emulsif
emulsions technology down in that range
uh you can get
fairly tight distributions uh
and it can be very reproducible the
overlays
on those were less than 0.1
cvs that's not to say that you get that
every time one of the things that can
test the stability
of that emulsion is to do
replicate runs and look to see whether
or not
it's maintaining its
size distribution over an extended
period of time
but to answer the question those were
approximately
or less than 0.1 percent
cbs coefficient of variation variability
can we use nano emulsions for delivering
transcription factors
can transcription
vectors
i would say the answer is
perhaps yes um i
as long as the transcript
transcription vectors can be protected
uh and engineered to be
appropriate size that allows them to go
through appropriate channels
uh you can use those as delivery tools
thank you for the cbd oils
could you again elaborate on what was
the difference between the two
techniques
uh sizing techniques
um this person says that they can't oh
i'm sorry
go ahead they couldn't understand which
plot to focus on
and their con question is really uh
surrounding the dilution
identical between the two techniques
they want to know if it's identical
okay excellent i can i can answer that
question
um once again uh i i
i mentioned that we we started
uh we did the emulsification with the
the high power sonicator
of these three different um
cbd oils uh
we then took them over
and started to measure
each one individually in the laser
diffraction
system uh and and
what you basically do there is you have
a carrier solution of water
circulating uh you go through the
various startup procedures
to do alignment and background checks
and then
uh start to pipette in the particles
uh the obscuration reading the amount of
particles being added will obscure the
beams
you want to hit to a particular size
obscuration value that is going to give
you
nice statistical accounting
and not do multiple scattering
and so once you have that you then run
it and
you can get those sizing results those
were the sharp
peaks that are displayed in the overlay
of those those are from laser
diffraction
what we literally did after that
measurement was done
is we pipetted out some of that solution
directly into a and
measured it with the dynamic like
scattering instrument
and so those are the results that uh
sizing results that we got with dlf for
the exact same
uh dilution
what range of emulsions do we get by
using sonication
uh we were able to emulsify
the emulsify
a five to ten man
five to ten micron emulsion
uh with um you know the lecifin
uh surfactant uh using the 200 watt
uh sonicator uh get
we got all the way down to in one
particular case about 16
60 nanometer um size
uh the other two went to
as low as a 110 and 130 nanometers
they basically were a result
of five minutes at
200 watts each of those
three results were done with the exact
same
process
thank you dr costello okay we have time
for
one more question so our last question
is for pids
is there a limit for dispersed phase
volume fraction
and could you elaborate on the
refractive index requirement
yeah um a limit on the dispersed
phase fraction uh
i can handle that a number of ways
um as the limit
this first phase fraction nice from a
sizing point of view
um we can go we can we physically
measure particles mean populations down
to 10 nanometers we can go a little bit
lower that than that
it depends on the
the level of scattering because now
you're getting to extremely small
particle sizes
and you know the amount of scattering
that's going on
so we typically
will go with fairly small
observation values down in that range
because we might
want to minimize multiple scattering
and so we load up in the case of
these kinds of uh populations
uh we will load up with
any anywhere from the i can only quote
on what the
population is in terms of obscuration
values
we typically will go with about 10 to
20 percent observation value
with these kinds of emulsions because
you start to get lots of
of multiple scattering it will smear the
beam somewhat
refractive index modeling we pretty much
attempt to use the
the values that we we can get
from the refractometer
and uv vis absorbance
however we are continuing to move
smaller and smaller and and and
really testing the optical properties of
these particles and so
i think everyone in particle size
analysis down in that range
regime will have to be that much more
cognizant of what how those optical
properties
of these smallest of particles are going
to be changing and affected
in solution so that will
continually continue to evolve with
solutions
thank you again dr costello do you have
any final comments for our audience
today
um i just want to thank everyone for
the excellent questions as well as
participating
and i wish them all a very safe and
healthy 2020 and future
thank you before we go i would like to
thank
again the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration
we would like to thank you dr john
costello for your time today in your
important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor beckmann coulter life
sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye